una retórica hostil contra los migrantes
motivada por la radicalización del
discurso y los estigmas eso es lo que ha
generado la pandemia sobre la migración
según la onu software divertido índices
hemos dedicado un capítulo a la
desinformación sobre la migración ice
john buck migration can have que puede
ayudar a mitigar o prevenir el daño
causado por los actores nefastos que
buscan socavar las discusiones
equilibradas sobre la michigan to under
mind balance discussions and grace jones
a pesar de la crisis sanitaria y las
restricciones la organización evidenció
que la migración internacional aumentó
272 millones en 2019 a 281 millones en
2020 aunque es un aumento menor a las
proyecciones por otra parte los
movimientos entre países desarrollados
se han incrementado
de los 20 principales países de origen
en 2020 y aquí excluimos a las
poblaciones de refugiados y populations
haití 18 de 20 de ellos tenían un índice
de desarrollo humano alto o muy alto on
the human development index
en perth en comparación con sólo 7 en
1995 agente night fights el informe
también muestra que un aumento en los
movimientos internos motivados por
desastres naturales que obligaron a
migrar a cerca de 7 millones de personas
y 48 millones más huyeron de conflictos
y otros tipos de violencia según la oim
los cerca de dos años de pandemia
modificaron radicalmente la manera en
que los humanos se mueven por la tierra
y a pesar de los incrementos el informe
también destaca que las medidas
restrictivas provocaron una inmovilidad
sin precedentes en la historia reciente
del mundo